for people who don't know obviously we
like to lump in Northern California
together a lot people will even like who
don't know better will say think mozzy's
from the bay no he's from Sacramento
he's from Sacramento but everyone just
loves to hold but shout out Mozzy a lot
of bait [__] won't say this because
they cornballs but uh what Mozzy did
shed a lot of light on the bay too for
sure yeah so salute Mozzy that's yeah
for sure I was gonna say though being
from Oakland obviously Oakland is kind
of like the flavor of the area in my
opinion open is the mecca of California
if you ask me so kind of break down like
coming from Oakland what is the
difference between in your opinion like
because I feel like Oakland
and Vallejo Loki have kind of
historically popped more than artists
from San Francisco obviously burner's
dope uh the 24 Karat golden kid just
went platinum I think
um but but like breakdown like why you
say it's the epicenter of culture and
why Oakland is just different from
everywhere else
um you have to realize
um
so um
let's go back historically black
panthers right uh that movement sparked
a worldwide change you get what I'm
saying
um from what the Panthers did
um they say the Crips for example day
literature
help you know start that not saying that
the Black Panther started that but that
literature with the Black Panthers was
pushing the Crips organization started
off that you get what I'm saying
um black panthers they reaching with
they stuff what they stood for was so
dope they had
um chapters in Chicago and New York and
um they did so much and then it's like
the game like um
the Mac was filmed in Oakland like you
get what I'm saying they had to come to
where that [__] was real like you get
what I'm saying they filmed the whole
Mac in Oakland um let's start from the
crack the dope era like one of the first
places in the world that sold crack
cocaine was Oakland you get what I'm
saying um Oakland just on some positive
[__] um look at the uh the athletes that
came out of Oakland
um the uh I think it was Bill Russell
just a lot of flavor just comes from
that little city you get what I'm saying
and I think it's because of look
kill me if I'm wrong right so when um
was it Eldritch Cleaver I think it was
Elders Cleaver when Elders Cleaver was
running for mayor of Oakland
it was Bobby seals I think one of them
two Eldridge or Bobby seals one of them
when they was running for Mayors when he
was running for mayor of Oakland right
all these brothers these Smart Sharp
individuals from all these uh chapters
of the Black Panthers from Chicago or
New York the South all these brothers
descended on Oakland to help push him
into that right this is like the 70s 60s
70s they all came to Oakland to help
push and get people to vote go
door-to-door so but when all these
brothers coming they sending their best
Brothers they sending um the top
Scholars the top gang spitters the top
whatever it is in in your field they
sending all these top Brothers on
Oakland and guess what these [__] was
doing when they coming they [__] our
[__] they having babies by these hoes
you feel me crazy yeah and what that was
doing is like I said these are top game
spitters top people from that genre they
[__] these [__] they uh doing all
type of [__] and um boom from their
babies they was having our parents and
[__] like that and just all this good
gang was just in this gumbo boxes
soaking up and [__] like that so Oakland
is so different and so like even
Immaculate in so many different areas
like um
how we talk we shake California
um the way we dress like I remember when
[__] when you seen a [__] with dreads
and gold teeth are they from Oakland you
get what I'm saying now everybody you
see a [__] with dreads yeah we talking
about on this side though you feel me
yeah you see a [__] with um you
know certain [__] hot [__] talk
what's up with my partner man you know
what I'm saying all right the lingo like
okay that [__] from Oakland he slick to
the [__] now everybody talking
like that everybody got some type of
gimmick or some Gander to run so Oakland
is the mecca of all that [__] for sure
um who are some of the artists out of
Oakland right now that you uh want to
shed some light on that might be doing
their thing ah man I really hate how to
say outside of yourself always miss
people that's fair man I really hate it
who you working with
um in Oakland right now me for sure I'm
always push my [__] you feel me the uh
little goofies the beezies the Momos
imma always push my [__] but
um Oakland I want to say the whole
Oakland bro because
um
what Oakland is doing right now and I'm
seeing this shift it used to be hella
political it's still political as [__]
but um Oakland is starting to embrace
Oak to embrace Oakland you get what I'm
saying like they're starting to support
each other and um and the reason why I
don't like singling our names and [__]
because you know there'd be somebody
watching this interview like uh he said
this [__] and them [__] [__] with
this [__] new [__] right you get what
I'm saying so I'm just gonna share it
inadvertently
it's going to right I mean so shout out
to East shout out to North shout out the
west and you know it's [__] from all
through Oakland that's doing their [__]
right now for sure